féminin j'ai beaucoup de de savoir être
et de savoir faire d'un commandement
donc voilà on ça reste une force quand
même qui est essentiellement masculine
mais au sein de laquelle les femmes vous
montrer
leur capacité manoeuvrière et leurs
capacités de conception de manoeuvre
s'agissant des eaux qui si nous arrivons
au terme de cette émission un grand
merci en tout cas à vous général
lefrançois de l'asu jeunes d'avoir
partagé sur le plateau de la grande
interview vos travail sur l'histoire du
maintien de l'ordre en france mais aussi
votre réaction par rapport aux dernières
actualités cette émission est avant voir
sur notre site rt france pointé vais
vous pouvez également l'écouter en
podcast à très bientôt sur notre antenne
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc il réalise des hôpitaux visés et
il était nulle part est ce qu'on peut
vivre malgré cette douleur quand j'ai
écrit à la fois je souffrais parce que
ça me rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
elle a une la coop 26 tente d'arracher
un accord aux forceps
elle devait s'achever hier mais les
négociations se poursuivent des acteurs
des 200 pays participant retiennent leur
souffle il ya bien un nouveau projet de
déclaration finale
des avancées espérer à l'incertitude
demeure à glasgow
la pandémie a fait plus de 5 millions de
morts dans le monde un dernier bilan ce
samedi en europe le regain épidémique
force de nombreux pays à prendre de
nouvelles restrictions et relancer
également les appels à la vaccination en
allemagne ou en autriche chez nous même
tendance de fond points dans cette
édition
et puis on soudan au moins cinq morts
dans des manifestations contre le coup
d'état militaire du 25 octobre dernier
de nombreux blessés également à ce
samedi des dizaines de milliers de
partisans d'un pouvoir civil en plus
face à forces de sécurité qui ont tiré à
balles réelles et fait usage de grenades
lacrymogènes
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france un accord ou
pas il ne reste plus beaucoup de temps
aux acteurs de la coop 26 à glasgow la
conférence internationale sur le climat
devait s'achever hier les négociations
se poursuivent à la présidence
britannique de la coop 26 défend bec et
ongles un projet de déclaration finale
mais qui peine à faire l'unanimité faute
de consensus notamment sur l'aide aux
pays les plus pauvres elle est moins
pollueur mais les plus impactés par le
réchauffement climatique
londres a espère toujours le limiter à
1,5 degré rester ainsi à fidèle à la
corde paris alors est-ce réellement
ambitieux écoutez l'avis de fabien
bouglé les spécialistes en énergie
auteur du livre nucléaire la vérité
cachée
la cop16 a rappelé l'importance de des
difficultés liées aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
ou comment dire aux aux énergies
fossiles pétrole gaz et charbon et là on
est au coeur je pense du questionnement
puisque une étude de harvard expliqué
que les émissions liées aux énergies
fossiles conduisait à 10 millions de
morts par an aujourd'hui on le voit on a
un départ en europe sur la question de
la taxonomie c'est-à-dire l'introduction
du nucléaire dans la liste des activités
vertes et finalement la coop annecy ce
n'est pas comme pas du tout la question
de la décarbonation parole le nucléaire
probablement que la cop16 a loupé une
occasion d'avancer plus fort au niveau
international dans le cadre du rapport
du giec qui avaient été publiées en 2018
et c'est là où le bât blesse à mon avis
dans le cadre des réflexions actuelles
et en tout cas ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les annonces des manuels
macron annonce nouvelle donne en matière
énergétique en france dans ce choc face
aux chocs gazier que nous connaissons en
europe n'aurait effectivement tout est
un peu brouillée mais globalement la
france a des atouts incontestables dans
ceux d'entre nous au jeu qui est en
train de se dessiner en france la
sixième rencontre annuelle à des
lanceurs d'alerté se déroule depuis hier
et pour trois jours à la plaine saint
denis sur place ce samedi à le père de
julian assange le fondateur de wikileaks
on parlait à l'instant de la coop 26 et
bien au menu aussi l'environnement a
notamment ou encore la protection des
personnes qui révèle des scandales est
les précisions sur place de notre
reporter lucas léger
c'est un programme très chargé qui est
proposé aux visiteurs de cette sixième
rencontre annuelle des lanceurs d'alert
sur trois jours des personnalités
politiques des journalistes des auteurs
des militants et des lances hors d'air
se succèdent ici à saint denis sur des
sujets aussi divers que l'écologie le
financement public la santé autant de
domaines dans lesquels les lanceurs d
alerte on joue un rôle prépondérant
ces dernières années cet événement est
soutenu par plusieurs organisations
comme anticorps greenpeace ou encore la
ligue des droits de l'homme ou encore la
maison des lanceurs d'alerté qui
regroupe 40 organisations cette année
est marquée par l'incertitude sur le
sort de julian assange le journaliste
risque toujours 175 ans de prison aux
états unis les états unis qui veulent le
faire extrader de grande bretagne je
vous propose d'écouter john shipton
présents ici le père de julian assange
qui nous a parlé tout à l'heure
le meilleur scénario serait que la
france offre l'asile à julian assange
seule la france peut sauver julian à ce
stade après 12 ans de persécutions
incessantes de traque continue de
malveillance sauvage de toujours plus
d'accusations scandaleuses de mensonges
et de calomnies seule la france peut à
ce stade sauver julian de l'extradition
aux etats-unis
c'est-à-dire la rencontre aussi une
résonance particulière puisque la
semaine prochaine sera débattu à
l'assemblée nationale une proposition de
loi du député modem sylvain waserman qui
à renforcer en france dans la
législation le statut des lanceurs
d'alerté déjà protégés par la loi un
sapin de il s'agit de l'adaptation d'une
directive européenne de 2000 19 sur le
sujet mais la loi est plus ambitieuse
comme l'ont expliqué plusieurs
intervenants que j'ai interrogés hier je
vous propose de les écouter pour que la
protection soit réel qu'elles soient
concrètes ce qui va compter autant que
la loi c'est les moyens qui vont être
mis à disposition de la justice des
autorités indépendantes qui vont être
chargés de protéger effectivement les
lanceurs d alerte et puis aussi
l'information du public et ça on attend
aussi du gouvernement qu'il fasse
connaître des dispositifs de protection
des lanceurs d'alerté parce que demain
monsieur ou madame tout le monde qui se
trouvent en situation d'être
potentiellement lanceurs d'alerté ne
sait pas forcément quels sont ses droits
comment les faire valoir et à qui
s'adresser pour être protégés et on peut
encore aller plus loin nous c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on proposera aussi au
sénat sur plusieurs sur plusieurs
dispositions et notamment en encadrant
encadrement des lanceurs d'alerté que ça
soit sur l'aspect financier c'est à dire
aussi un annonceur dallaire pour faire
en sorte comment il ne perd pas il ne
perd pas son emploi comment il peut
avoir un fonds d'indemnisation quand il
ya des procédures je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose d'important pour l'instant
et c'est un sort alerte s'est reconnu
qu' à titre individuel et du coup une
personne morale n'est pas reconnue donc
associations syndicats et ça c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est important qu'ils
aient même il gérait primordial et qu'il
faut vraiment qui pour l'instant n'est
pas dans le texte le 4 novembre en amont
de ce débat parlementaire qui va avoir
lieu un collectif de représentants des
ong et de syndicalistes ont signé une
tribune dans le monde pour rappeler à
quel point le statut de lanceurs
d'alerté est important dans la
démocratie ils ont notamment rappelé que
douze propositions avaient été faites
pour renforcer la loi actuelle certaines
ont été reprises par le député
wassermann reste maintenant à savoir ce
que va devenir ce texte après les débats
à l'assemblée nationale
elle la pandémie a fait plus de 5
millions de morts dans le monde et
l'europe est en alerte face à un regain
épidémique de nombreux pays prennent à
de nouvelles restrictions et appelle à
se faire vacciner en allemagne pourrait
y avoir à déconfinement régionaux en
autriche on réfléchit à confiner les
non-vaccinés aux pays-bas mise sous
cloche partiel est entré en vigueur
aujourd'hui on fait le point avec
françois xavier lambert
un confinement nationale pour les
autrichiens n'ont vacciné alors que plus
de dix mille nouveaux cas sont
enregistrés chaque jour en autriche le
gouvernement s'est donc décidé à prendre
une mesure radicale les personnes
concernées n'auront pas le droit de
quitter leur domicile sauf pour faire
leurs courses du sport ou se faire
soigner
d'abord réticent ces nouvelles
restrictions l'exécutif autriche a revu
sa position face à l'insuffisance du
tout de vaccination de la population
près de 65% a reçu ces deux doses de
vaccin un chiffre inférieur à la moyenne
européenne évalué à 67% dans ce contexte
le chancelier appelle ses concitoyens à
une prise de conscience
je vous invite à utiliser cette
possibilité de se faire vacciner
les taux de vaccination sont
honteusement bas va utiliser cette
opportunité
laissez-vous être protégé protégez vous
protéger les autres nous voulons tous
que cela se termine rapidement mais nous
voyons une situation nous avons besoin
d'un confinement national pour les
personnes non vaccinées
pour que ces restrictions s'appliquent à
l'ensemble de l'autriche le parlement
doit encore donner son feu vert ce
dimanche tout comme l'ensemble des
gouverneurs de région l'autriche qui re
a par ailleurs encore plus loin à vienne
la vaccination concernera les seuls onze
ans une première en europe hormis
l'autriche la pandémie s'accélère
également aux pays bas jeudi plus de 16
mille nouveaux cas de co vides ont été
recensés mais dans le cas des airs lors
dé cette dégradation n'est pas liée à un
taux de vaccination trop bas
82 % des plus de 12 ans i saw
entièrement vacciner face à la menace
d'une saturation des hôpitaux
le premier ministre marque route annonce
lui aussi au confinement partielle un
vent tu
lises hôtels les magasins et tout ce qui
relève des services non essentiels
devront obligatoirement fermé leurs
portes à une heure donnée à retoucher
avance
qu'à tous les hôtels supermarchés et
autres magasins essentiels seront fermés
entre 20h et 6h du matin j'ai un
jugement mais ces nouvelles restrictions
sont rejetés par une partie de la
population qui revendique sa liberté à
l'ail et près de 200 manifestants ont
été dispersés par la police devant le
ministère de la justice où se tenait la
conférence de presse gouvernementale
pas de quoi faire reculer l'exécutif dr
lors des les nouvelles mesures entrent
en vigueur dès ce samedi soir et pour
une durée d'au moins trois semaines et
que tf copé ou berthod giovanni millet
médecin un chirurgien
ses choix politiques d'abord et
d'étudiants qui sont conclus par les
ions poétique est à part les médecins
tél 15 médecin en pc on peut dire qu'ils
ont va confiné et auterive d'écho chez
les personnes à risque donc c'est
possible qu'elle ait non vaccinés sur
des personnes à risque mais encore
encore faut-il les cités par exemple est
ce qu il faut qu aucune est quelqu'un
qui a 30 ans qui est en bonne santé et
qu'ils aient pas des craquements des
risques je ne sais pas et sachant aussi
que les vaccins étaient ils sont pas les
vaccins comme on a connu auparavant
parce qu'elle est mais il n'empêche pas
d'être mal à dire décontractée oui j'y
vais il empêche d'être malade mais
n'empêche pas décontracté vidéo il
n'empêche pas des transmettre le virus
alors il faut voir pourquoi on confine
est ce qu on confine pour protéger les
plus fragiles est ce qu on confine pour
pousser les gens qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés à se vacciner oui les décisions
sont différents entre temps qui m'était
nous on irait confiner les gens fragiles
et les gens à risque mais on compte une
part les gens pas vacciner
et on en vient la crise migratoire à la
frontière entre la biélorussie et la
pologne source de tension entre ces deux
pays aient les deux camps se renvoient
la balle menacés par de nouvelles
sanctions européennes links qui promet
de riposter
varsovie elle pointe du doigt également
la russie le président russe rejette
toute responsabilité et appelle au
dialogue sur place vous ouvriez des
milliers de migrants sont bloqués depuis
des jours dans des conditions
humanitaires désastreuses ont fait le
point avec heures quand un mot clary
amina ben t'as
un camp de fortune sous des températures
de plus en plus basses alors que des
centaines de migrants s'entassent à la
frontière en espérant passer en pologne
minsk prévient qu'elle répondra de
manière instantanée en cas d'attaqué
extérieure
on a l'impression que nos voisins
occidentaux et notamment la pologne sont
prêts tout en résolvant leurs problèmes
politiques internes ainsi que leurs
relations au sein de l'union européenne
a déclenché un conflit dans lequel ils
veulent entraîner l'europe gameplay
le langage des ultimatums des menaces et
du chantage est inacceptable les forces
armées de la république de biélorussie
sont prêtes à riposter sévèrement à
toute attaque la biélorussie avait déjà
tenté de faire pression jeudi en
menaçant de rompre l'approvisionnement
en gaz de l'europe des menaces tempéré
par son amie russe qui assure que
l'alimentation énergétique n'est pas un
moyen de pression à l'ordre du jour
varsovie a déployé 15 mille soldats à la
frontière pour empêcher des migrants de
rentrée
ces gens sont approvisionnés en bois
pour faire du feu et en os la
croix-rouge bélarus leur a aussi donné
des provisions donc on voit que les
soldats se prépare à un plus long séjour
de ces personnes à la frontière
y a t il encore dit
nous avons fait face à une situation peu
courante et dangereuse les autorités
bélarusses ont visé les soldats polonais
avec des lasers verts
la situation inquiète au delà des
frontières entre les deux pays
washington n'a pas manqué de s'exprimer
c'est une source de grande inquiétude
nous avons fait part de nos
préoccupations à la russie nous avons
fait part de nos inquiétudes à la
biélorussie moscou estime qu'une issue
au problème ne dépend pas seulement de
minsk mais aussi de l'union européenne
je veux que tout le monde sache que nous
n'avons rien à voir avec ceux là ils
essaient de nous en faire porter la
responsabilité pour n'importe quelle
raison et même sans aucune raison ce ne
sont pas nos compagnies aériennes qui
transportent ces personnes en fait
aucune de nos entreprises ne les
transporte d'ailleurs bellavia comme l'a
dit loukachenko ne transporte pas non
plus ces personnes
je tiens à souligner une fois de plus
que la russie n'a absolument rien à voir
avec cette affaire ne sommes pas du tout
impliqués dans ce processus de leur côté
des nations unies appelle les deux
parties à penser avant tout aux migrants
bloqués dans des camps de fortune
notre message à toutes les parties et
que les gens ne doivent pas être
instrumentalisée ils ne sont pas des
pions ce sont des êtres humains en fin
de compte ce qui doit se passer c'est
que leurs besoins fondamentaux et leurs
droits fondamentaux doivent être prises
en charge selon human rights watch plus
de deux mille personnes seraient
actuellement bloqués à la frontière
l'union européenne a accusé la
biélorussie d'acheminer ces migrants aux
portes de l'europe devant ces
accusations la turquie a annoncé ce
vendredi suspendre ses vols à
destination de la biélorussie pour les
ressortissants yéménites syriens et
turcs de son côté le royaume uni a
déployé un groupe de militants venus
prêter main forte aux gardes-frontière
détention a diplomatic certes mais
l'affrontement militaire est encore loin
selon l'analyste politique et
spécialiste des pays de l'europe de
l'est ce nicholas markowitz mirkovic et
on l'écouté oui non je pense pas qu'il y
aura pas de mouvement mais et militaires
des deux côtés veux leur montrer leurs
muscles ça c'est certain ça c'est propre
à général hamel espérer des militaires
ce qui est intéressant décès de ce que
vous venez de dire pourquoi est-ce que
la pologne fait appel à un militaire
britannique qui ne fait ne font plus
partie de l'union européenne ça c'est un
signal fort dire que les polonais ne
font même pas appel à leurs voisins
européens pour les aider à les défendre
l'union européenne envoie pas de
militaires pour défendre la pologne la
pologne fait appel un pays qui en dehors
de l'union européenne c'est quand même
un signe c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important la pologne elle
est tiraillée et elle est tiraillée ne
sait plus quoi faire elle ne veut pas de
l'immigration et l'a déjà dit mais
étaient sanctionnés par bruxelles parce
que la piquette voulait pas trop peu
tard à d'immigrés aujourd'hui bruxelles
se servent de la pologne comme pion dans
un jeu au pied plus grands qui est
contre la russie et la biélorussie la
pologne la délai d'un an de cette farce
c'est la politique afin de se faire
avoir elle ne sait plus quoi faire et tu
sais plus quoi faire elle voudrait
plaire à bruxelles voudrait faire à
washington mais on voit bien qu'il est
qu'elle est limité dans ses moyens
aujourd'hui
au cédant 1,5 mandanda nouvelle
manifestation contre le coup d'état du
25 octobre dernier on déplore également
de nombreux blessés par balles ce samedi
ils étaient des dizaines de milliers
déployés dans le pays pour dire non au
coup de force militaire et demandé le
retour du pouvoir civil est les forces
de sécurité ont tiré à balles réelles et
fait usage de grenades lacrymogènes
écouter ces réactions de manifestants à
khartoum
le travail de l'armée n'est pas d'être
au pouvoir ou en politique mais de
protéger la constitution contre laquelle
abdel fattah al burana s'est retourné
après avoir prêté serment de la
respecter
notre demande est de faire tomber le
conseil militaire est de ramener le
gouvernement civil nous sommes fatigués
du régime militaire et nous espérons qu
aucun soldat ne nous gouvernera
est toujours dans la corne de l'afrique
les etats unis mettent la pression sur
l'erythrée dans le compte les au tigré
washington a donc c'était sanctions
visant directement l'armée le pouvoir
érythréen à le secrétaire d'état anthony
blinken précise que l'ethiopie est
épargné afin que les discussions avec le
tplf le front de libération du peuple du
tigré se poursuivre l'erythrée qui a
soutenu militairement addis abeba à
condamne ces sanctions estime être un
bouc émissaire
il est évident que l'objectif premier de
ces sanctions illicites et immoral et de
faire souffrir et d' affamer la
population afin de provoquer des
troubles politiques et l'instabilité ces
sanctions unilatérales qui rejette la
responsabilité sur l'erythrée et en font
un bouc émissaire sur la base
d'allégations fallacieuses
contreviennent au droit international et
constitue une violation flagrante de
souveraineté
six ans après l'horreur la france rend
hommage à toutes les victimes des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 130 morts
plus de 350 blessés visé par un commando
terroriste
accompagné à d'officiels ce matin jean
castex le premier ministre a déposé une
gerbe de fleurs devant le stade de
france il a ensuite pris la direction
des terrasses de café du bataclan et du
bataclan à paris un hommage alors que le
procès est en cours écouter ces
témoignages recueillis lors des
commémorations
cette année c'est en fait quasiment la
dernière année où le bataclan fait
partie intégrante de la de la mémoire
collective donc pour nous il ya pas mal
de choses qui se joue c'est un peu là la
fin du cycle 2
pas de commémoration mais en tout cas de
de notre rencontre construction c'est un
moment clé pour nous et ce qui se dit
pendant le procès ce que nous on a dit
et ce qui est dit par les magistrats par
les accusés par les par les autres
parties civiles se dépose et va rester
gravé dans le marbre donc cette année
oui c'est important 2
vraiment le vivre à fond et de marquer
le coup en fait on on commémore des
événements qu'on est en train de juger
en même temps donc c'est une espèce de
surcouche mémorielle ça rajoute une
espèce d'expérience collective sur
l'expérience collective
donc c'est voilà c'est une sorte de
paradoxe un peu bizarre mais je pense
que je suis à bien tu l'as bien tu as
bien résumé quoi bon c'est un moment
historique pour nous dans notre histoire
personnelle mais aussi dans l'histoire
collective deux pas de paris et de la
france soit 13 novembre à 2015 paris et
sa banlieue
touché en plein coeur à le procès des
attentats est hors norme la première
phase vient de se terminer les
témoignages des victimes et de leurs
proches ont révélé bien plus que
l'horreur à sébastien chabal
le 8 septembre 2021 le procès des
attentats du 13 novembre s'ouvre à paris
dans une salle spécialement construite
pour l'événement
certaines personnes qui ont été blessées
ou qui ont perdu un proche ne souhaitent
pas nécessairement s'exprimer pourquoi
parce que la souffrance est indicible
elle est inexprimable mais ce qu'elles
attendent c'est une justice
particulièrement ferme les actes qui
sont reprochés aux accusés sont des
actes particulièrement monstrueux durant
six à huit mois plus de 300 témoins vont
se succéder face à la cour et aux
accusés parmi eux salah abdeslam seul
survivant des commandos du groupe etat
islamique
le premier jour du procès a été
consacrée à l'appel des accusés des
parties civiles et de leur avocat salahe
abdeslam s'est montré provocateur en
commençant par dire tout d'abord je
tiens à témoigner qu'il n'y a pas de
divinité à part à l'ats que mohammed est
son serviteur et son messager
mais hier je suis sorti en miettes
clairement
pour plein de raisons parce qu'il ya
déjà quand on rentre ici hier matin
c'était l'effervescence incroyable donc
ça c'était vraiment un truc
et on prend conscience uniquement quand
on le vicois clairement
ensuite il ya eu l'entrée du président
ça c'était vraiment un moment d'une
intensité
extrême il ya eu l'impression que tout
vous submerge voudrait tout on revient à
ce moment là quoi c'est vraiment un
moment a vraiment un
moyen idoine quoi sur
l'institution la société enfin tout tout
est là tout est réuni à ce moment là
selon moi à partir du 28 septembre les
témoignages des rescapés et des proches
des victimes commencent une séquence
longue de cinq semaines
cité comme témoin par l'association de
victimes life for parisse l'ancien
président françois hollande s'est
exprimé le 10 novembre ce témoignage je
le dois à toutes les victimes à celles
et ceux qui ne sont plus là je sais la
souffrance que les victimes ont exprimé
devant la cour et je répondrai à toutes
les questions
[Musique]
je pense que françois hollande nous a
permis de mieux comprendre quel était le
degré de connaissance de l'état sur les
projets de l'état islamique à l'époque
sur ce qui avait pu être mis en oeuvre
il a aussi fait la lumière en partie sur
les opérations de police ce soir là en
disant qu'il avait donné son accord de
principe
dès son arrivée à la cellule place
bourgault et tous ces éléments là en
fait n'apparaissait pas encore au
dossier n'était jamais apparu dans des
interviews donc on a appris des choses
et c'était ça le sens de le faire venir
aujourd'hui les accusés seront entendus
sur les faits dès janvier les premières
plaidoiries des parties civiles auront
lieu début avril pour un verdict attendu
à la fin du mois de mai
écoutez michel fize éditorialiste à pour
arte france
c'est une scène de guerre donc c'est une
sorte de guerre civile qui a eu lieu à
l'intérieur du bataclan et évidemment
sur les terrasses des cafés au stade et
au stade de france j'ai vu ce matin dans
la presse quotidienne des des
témoignages absolument auris est
ahurissant de gueules cassées de corps
de corps déchiquetés je crois qu'on n'a
pas conscience encore une fois de 2,2 de
l'effroyable effroyable bilité de
l'événement on est dans une société très
perturbée avec dédé des individus qui
n'ont plus les repères qu'avait
peut-être nos aînés enfermés dans des
classes sociales qu'il est qu'il est
protégé et en tout cas qui leur
permettait de ne pas dépasser un certain
nombre de limites je pense qu'encore une
fois les psychologies aujourd'hui son
sont fragiles et les souffrances sont
grandes par conséquent
évidemment le dérapage est possible
puisqu'on parle beaucoup de prévention
de santé qu'il faudrait peut-être
dans la réforme peut-être de la santé
que l'on devrait accomplir les
prochaines années il faudrait peut-être
effectivement permettre à chacun de
passer un examen de santé un examen de
santé psychologique pas là pour éviter
évidemment la multiplication de ces
loups solitaires
et ont conclu avec terre l'inculpation
de l'ancien conseiller de donald trump
steve banal à ce dernier a est accusé
d'avoir refusé d'apporter son témoignage
dans l' enquête sur le rôle de l'ancien
président dans l'assaut du capitole
c'était le 6 janvier dernier les
explications avec amina benkhadra et
mais dsk fait
une enquête ralenti à cause d'un homme
son nom steve banane l'ancien conseiller
de donald trump est inculpé pour avoir
refusé de témoigner dans la sphère de la
tacc du capitole
un témoignage pourtant attendus dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur le rôle de
l'ancien président américain dans cette
attaque pour le procureur général
l'application de la loi justifie cette
décision à l'encontre de bananes de son
côté le président du comité souhaite que
cette décision serve d'avertissement
et bien que nous soyons déterminés à
obtenir toutes les informations que nous
cherchons monsieur me dose monsieur
bananes et d'autres qui suivent cette
voie ne réussiront pas à arrêter les
efforts de la commission spéciale pour
obtenir des réponses pour le peuple
américain sur le 6 janvier faire des
recommandations législatives pour aider
à protéger notre démocratie et des à
garantir que rien de tel que ce jour ne
se reproduise jamais même si steve van
n'occupait pas de fonctions officielles
lorsque l'assaut a eu lieu il est
soupçonné d'avoir parlé de la
manifestation avec donald trump les
jours précédents selon la commission
denquête le 6 janvier dernier alors que
mike pence vice président des états unis
refusent de contester les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle remportée par
joe biden le clan pro trump accuse le
coup et chauffé par le président sortant
via les réseaux sociaux les trump heist
marche sur le capitole
[Applaudissements]
une attaque qui coûtera d'ailleurs à
donald trump la clôture de son compte
twitter s'il est reconnu coupable banen
risque jusqu'à un an de prison et une
amende pouvant aller jusqu'à 100 mille
dollars ch'ti banane qui ne s'est pas
présenté devant les élus en invoquant le
droit de tout président a gardé certains
documents et discussions confidentielles
un argument rejeté par la commission
donald trump n'étant plus président et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de la version va se retrouver dans
une trentaine de minutes rester avec mon
frère clés france
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que mon le
l'ouest était écolo mais que l'est et
paul bert moi je suis point